[Music]
[Music]
without context to the premise of Tetris
effect won't stop you in your tracks
it's Tetris at heart and it's familiar
play field is presented against fantasy
backdrops and songs and sound effects
that react to your actions
what that basic description doesn't tell
you though is how powerful the
combination of conducting tetrominos and
music at the same time can be give
Tetris effect your complete undivided
attention and you'll form a sympathetic
bond to the notes and puzzle pieces
alike and lose yourself in the flurry of
color and energy that permeates every
stage it's a lofty promise to be sure
but there's no other way to describe the
impact Tetris effect has once it finally
clicks
[Music]
although there's no multiplayer there
are a handful of modes with basic twists
on the standard formula that are worth
exploring at your leisure
but the bulk of the tetris effect
experience takes place in journey mode
it's an aptly named trip that will take
you to recognizable locations like the
moon but more often to abstract settings
that are best defined by a list of
adjectives these dreamscapes can be
breezy electric stressful haunting
heavenly crunchy it's name a few of the
standout qualities the music in each
stage may not always be a predictable
pairing but just because you didn't see
a particular harmony coming doesn't mean
it can't work over time you will notice
that the game not only hooks you with
music but that it gets you hooked on
songs that may not traditionally fit
within your musical preferences odds are
you to listen to chanting in foreign
languages nor the complicated beats of
the table on a daily basis but Tetris
effect makes these uncommon sounds
enticing it's hard to say what these
songs would feel like without first
experiencing them during gameplay but
when you're enraptured in their rhythms
while simultaneously flipping and
reconfiguring puzzle pieces in a race
against time they become relentlessly
catchy sticking with you long after you
stop playing
[Music]
because tetras effect is so infectious
it's very difficult to put down once you
fall into its rhythm Tetris has proven
itself to be a highly effective game and
one that has an ever-rising skill
ceiling that allows it to draw in
players who have decades of experience
under their belts Tetris effect will
ramp up but in keeping with the sense of
going on a journey it will also slump
down no rarely for long but nonlinear
flow is an important part of the
experience that charges you with
anticipation and rewards you with relief
and is an unexpected benefit to the
standard flow of a session of Tetris
[Music]
[Music]
the shift in toning pace is often
determined by your progress within a
stage most require you to clear 36 lines
total with milestones along the way that
dictate the present rhythm
you do however have a helpful tool at
your disposal the zone mode when
activated it is designed to pump the
brakes and give you a chance to salvage
a potentially disastrous situation or to
build up a high score that wouldn't
otherwise be possible zone is a solid
addition to the tetris formula but it's
the quasi spiritual bond that forms
between you and the game that defines
Tetris effect
[Music]
and even though you don't need a psvr
headset to experience it there's no
question that Tetris effect is best
played in VR with headphones turned all
the way up with your vision and hearing
cut off from the outside world you fade
into the game you feel things you never
imagined a game of Tetris could make you
feel don't be surprised if you catch
yourself bursting with joy or on the
verge of tears all because the
confluence of gameplay and sensory
stimulation works so well there is no
extra physical movement asked of you the
opposite of almost every other VR game
every some memory Tetris effect wants
your mind rather than your body and even
though we all dream of one day being
completely immersed in a high-end VR
game in truth the tetris effect achieves
that base goal belief in your connection
to the game and it's already here
[Music]
[Music]
Tetris effect is a transformative game
that will more than likely be overlooked
by people who think it's just Tetris
well it is and it isn't
anyone who knows Tetris can pick up
Tetris effect and begin playing right
away the fundamentals remain the same it
is a time-tested formula that continues
to work after all
but Tetris is just the beginning of
Tetris effects it provides the
foundation for a complex emotional
journey that defies expectations it's a
vector for meditation it's a driving
force that pushes you beyond your
presumed limits it is the definition of
Awesome and if you have an open heart
and an open mind you owe it to yourself
to take the plunge and see why it's
anything but just Tetris
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]